you
hi everyone is jariyama and chest calms
tactics trainer and I'm gonna do a group
of three puzzles and just share my
thoughts along the way well every once
in a while you encounter a problem you
have seen before this happens to be one
I've seen before hmm
I think I got it the first passing with
this one but certainly a cool tactic hmm
okay so it's white to move as usual if
you like to play along with this and
figure it out on your own first
go for it I'll try you know I've seen
the puzzle that I know the solution to
this one just kind of double checking
what the answer is in trying to recall
what my thought process was when I saw
for the very first time uh-huh
okay so a sneaky move to start with this
one yeah
Oh actually I had the wrong idea
for starters okay I'm seeing it now yeah
okay so this is a combination of forks
by both minor pieces for a moment I was
drawn to the move and this is in fact a
way you can go wrong I was drawn to the
move Queen to h8 sneaky isn't it because
after King takes Queen there's now
Knight takes rook with the check and you
get that Queen right back two minor
pieces up versus two harmless pawns but
on Queen a chase for starters there is
King g6 you don't have to take the Queen
so the way to make sure that the king is
forced to take the Queen is to play this
move first Bishop takes e5 with the fork
because now when Queen AJ comes if the
King plays to g6 we pick up the Queen
but in this case
we go with the fork and then scoop up
the Queen and wear a piece up and it
solved
that's a sharp puzzle I like that one
yeah that's a good one it was awhile
since I seen that one but yeah good
problem highlighting forks and forks buy
a couple pieces alright let's check out
puzzle 2 team white alrighty
my first thought is you better do
something fast because you're ready to
get made it on each one so this one
should maybe not be so bad pretty much
are locked into forcing moves you really
have to give check I mean Bishop g2
Queen h1 you have to act fast so the
first move that I'm thinking about is a
knight check uh-huh what other cannon
moves are there I mean cuz this check
here is allowing an ensuing check and
there isn't another check to really go
forward with so I'm pretty sure it's
this move to start the only other check
is Queen takes pawn with
then you know there's ensuing checks on
v5 but after let's say King here or King
back yeah let's just say King back there
isn't a great follow up Queen takes King
takes Knight b5 King back to b8 you
could take twice on this square but then
after Bishop c8 that's it for successful
checks you could just give up the rook
for another check but so knight c6 it
should be the first move
ninety-six Bishop takes and then what
rook takes rook let's just say the
Knight takes rook takes rook King here
okay huh
knight c6 Bishop takes huh okay well
actually one thing to note is that on
Knight here check bishop here Bishop
takes the Queen could recapture I don't
think that that would be it but I just
want to reference when the Queen
recaptures she's now on the diagonal in
watching out for this Queen h1 idea also
Queen h1 immediately is not mate setting
up a making to idea Queen here Knight
takes rook takes would be mate
but let's see this again knight c6
Bishop takes Knight got a try out the
checking moves next rook takes rook
Knight takes rook takes Knight King here
so huh we have a real controlling the
back rank we have the King on b7 and a
bishop on c6 this Knight has gone all
these pieces are gone except for a white
rook now on d8 this Bishop can insert a
check on a six when the King steps up so
I should be looking at that hmm okay
nice
stakes take twice on this square king v7
would the move Bishop a six be the next
move King takes would be forced doesn't
feel right
I mean after King takes Bishop what are
you doing next it's up to the Queen to
give a follow-up check in there isn't
really a good check you know Queen here
but King b7 Noah hmm oh oh man
there's Queen takes bishop check oh man
that must be what it is
this is pulling the king towards the
center oh man okay
that must be what it is knight c6 Bishop
takes chopped twice here king b7 Queen
takes bishop King here pulling the king
out because we have this move as a
follow up bishop f3 which says no you
will not run back into your little home
and yeah that's that's probably going to
do it this will be a mate just trying to
work it out after Bishop f3 king c5
there is a knight block but we would
just take we have a rook on this d8
square now but let's just say the
immediate after Queen takes Bishop King
takes Bishop f3 King c5 where's the mate
there's enough
there's a pond I could give check for
one um yeah
where's the mate from that position the
bishop because the bishop on he won is
controlling b4 so b4 check would then
force King c4 and then oh I guess we
just returned to no naughty - because
the knight is controlling you - huh I'm
really close we're really close
I'm just trying to cap this one off here
I'm trying to see it because you know if
you just make the move and then get to
that position then try to solve it there
you're only ever thinking one or two
moves deep trying to see this one
through right to its end all right so we
have a bishop on f3 a black king that is
very short on squares on c5 in that
position and b4 seems to be crying out
to be played
huh that seen the final touch their king
is on c5 Bishop is on f3 the king from
that current position has no legal moves
okay but if we play b4 it takes away one
square but gives up another square
should we be even doing that should I be
looking for something other than b4 what
other checks would there be in that
position with the king on c5 there's
Knight checks but you know on d3 in here
but they could both be taken out hmm oh
oh you still play Bishop back to E - so
when the King is on c5 b4 King c4 no
that's not it
I was thinking Bishop here and after
Knight takes the other night comes in -
to give a check mate hmm I started
point here I can't I can't work that one
out yet King is on c5 the bishop is on
f3
there's b4 check King c4 and then what
hmm before king c4 oh maybe I should
the move order a little bit when the
king is on c5 instead of b4 is some
knight move better like a knight d3
check after Knight takes Knight yeah I
don't think that that's working either
oh man I really want to get this I know
this one's taking forever but uh um I
really I know I'm on the right track and
I want to be able to see it right from
this current position so yeah I just I
need more time so I'm going to focus on
trying to get work this one out I'm just
not seeing it huh
King is on c5 what do you do there the
bishop is on f3 everything is cleared
off of this file it's just a rook
patrolling this D file before check King
c4
oh I got it right out okay
the king is on c5 and then is 93 93 93
check oh man I'm so I feel like I am so
close I feel like I'm so close with this
one why can I not get this one mm-hmm
okay I'm gonna soldier on here I know
it's not the most exciting a thing to be
watching someone just having a tough
time figuring out a puzzle but yeah I'm
gonna stick with this one king c5 and I
don't know why something other than b4
b4 and 93 I keep going back to these two
I'm trying to find differences between
which one is better in that position
Knight d3 Knight takes Knight is forest
and then like you can't you can't follow
up with b3 at that point because the I
mean the knight is controlling that
square I was
something along the lines of you know
after the king is on this square night
d3 Knight takes Knight b4 and if King c4
there's Bishop d5 mate there might be
something to that hmm you know this is
taking forever maybe this would be the
last puzzle I do let's see and you know
what the sad thing is maybe some of you
can relate to this if you do enough
chess puzzles I think this is a puzzle
that I've had before at some point
somewhere
I've had this puzzle before and you know
he's just clear still clearly struggling
with it pretty sure I have that right
idea okay I'm still I'm pretty sure it's
this variation the king is on c5 No
are available I yeah I don't think any
quiet moves are available from that
position with the king on c5 before king
c4 ooh there is are you kidding me
there's rook d4 check in that position
after b4 after b4 King c4 there's a
rucksack with rook d4 o i think i'm
going too far out now oh man hmm before
king c4
for king takes then there's so many
other options for the king well not so
many but running out of pieces and the
king is ready to that and run away by
way of e5 for starters I think I'm ready
to throw in the towel with this one
losing hope most of you have helped most
of you have left if you're still here
watching this hats off to you you've got
a lot of patience well done um okay yeah
I just don't taking a glance at the
recording time its way up there
this will be the last puzzle I do I'm
exhausted
okay uh yeah let's let's let's recap
this one night check bishop chop chop
chop on d8 King b7 Queen takes Bishop
King takes Queen something other than
Bishop f3 at that point I don't think so
any other move the King gets to run away
here you gotta play Bishop here Bishop
f3 check King c5 come on you could do it
been here before
King c5 um man really want this one
b4 check I still want I'm still drawn to
be four check King c4 only move
I'm gonna be really proud if I don't
very frustrated actually I can't be too
proud but uh yeah I want to get this
before King C for I don't like before
for some reason
night night d3 Knight takes Knight
something else in that position
the king is has no legal moves from that
position with the bishop on f3 and when
he's on c5 no illegal moves I'm only
seeing b4 in Knight d3 as useful oh no
no no it's not here an idea I check here
steaks and then how would that even be
helpful sorry I'm not commenting I'm
just really focused now I actually not
very focused at all having trouble
seeing any other candidate moves I'm not
sure
to do here b4 and 93 hmm when the king
is on c5 b4 Knight d3 or e4 um there's
oh I might be onto something
oh no I think I saw just for a moment it
flashed right before my eyes
when the king is on c5 after Knight d3
check Knight takes Knight
there's rook d5 you goof that's gotta be
worth something that has got to be worth
something
I think I might be on the right track
now the king is on c5 we insert knight
d3 check forcing Knight takes Knight
because this is a freeing up the d5 d5
square then we could play rook d5 check
this would force king c6 and now we're
in a position to give discovered checks
or double checks now where does the
Ricoh from that position as I'm seeing
I'm seeing the position now with the a
black knight here white bishop here rook
on d5 King on c6 there's
six double check in then rook c6 mate
did I just get it no not quite the king
it could go to d4 at that point but then
Bishop c3 check
forcing King III are you kidding me and
then Knight d1 mate is that really is
that really it I have to do one last
recap I mean why not right I've already
spent a nearly a half an hour this is
crazy this and that went that last
variation I cited it was very fuzzy
cannot be completely sure of it but it's
a very lengthy one if that is it okay so
yeah check chop chop chop on d8 King b7
take the bishop give a check King c5
Knight d3 check Knight takes Knight
forest rook d5 check King c6 rook d6
double check King back to c5 rook c6
check the King now has one square
available d4 with the rook on c6 there's
now Bishop c3 check these squares are
all cut off there's only one legal move
King III
and night d1 actually would not be me
because the king could go to this square
ah
close I really feel like I'm so close
there rook d6 when that rook d6 move
hits with double check King here maybe
there's something better
yeah oh this is a first for sure this
type of struggle for video doing a
puzzle if you're still with me another
gold star most of you are long gone long
gone and maybe have already got typed
out a comment like are you kidding me I
hear you man I hear you ah king is on c5
we could go with this 93 check Knight
takes Knight Bishop check next yeah I
messed up right there King is on c5 yeah
okay so Knight d3 Knight takes Knight
rook d5 okay rook d5 King c6 is an only
move if they're just a maintenance
I
still think it it's rook d6 double check
King back to c5 rook c6 check King d4 oh
it's tough to see that position the rook
on c6 a bishop on f3 a black hang on d4
a black knight on d3
Bishop's III check King III is the only
move 91
you won't check King F for I don't think
he could hunt the King down when he's
there I mean you could come back with
the fish up to D to check actually
scratch that when the king is on e3 he's
attacking the bishop that we had on f3
that's not it
it still might be Knight d3 Knight takes
rook d5 King c6 something else is there
better instead of this double-checking
move something better than that
wait a second why do I have to go any
move any any rook move along the D file
well force King c5 so I don't have to go
through this d6 square I could go
somewhere else
ah you goof oh I got it man you could
play the d4 no that's not working either
that is okay I think
I think I have it here when the king is
on c5 here we do 93 Knight takes rook d5
check King c6 and then we could we could
take the knight actually that's on d3
that forces the King back to c5 then we
play b4 check King c4 and then Bishop d5
oh man okay bear with me just one more
pass on this I'm just gonna I'm gonna
put it on the board but I just want to
play through it I think I have it
finally Oh
Knight check Bishop takes chop-chop
twice on d8 King b7 Queen takes Bishop
King takes Queen Bishop f3 check King c5
Knight d3 check Knight takes Knight rook
d5 check King c6 rook takes Knight check
King c5v 4 check King c4 bishop d5 me I
hope that's it it's correct correct
correct so far so good check
is correct this is where I think there
might be a mistake
no it's correct I'm feeling better this
is what I said I'm just gonna put it on
the board it is solved that is correct
took you long enough
did I still have the correct follow-up
though king c6 I definitely have a mate
with taking the night king c5 b for king
C for Bishop d5 but would there have
been something faster I don't think so
pretty sure you have to move the rook
and in this position after king c5 you
have to move the rook just so the bishop
doesn't allow that came to get to b7 and
I think that that is that would be it
right there let me just a double check
here with the analysis board and yeah
I'm not doing a third fossil this is oh
yeah that was crazy long I think yeah
let's see if they have any notes
yes king c6 rook takes d king c5 b for
check king C for Bishop d5 I got it ok
I'm happy well I would have liked to
have gotten it faster but I don't know
what to say I guess I stuck with it huh
not the easiest thing to do very easy to
just lose hope you probably heard it in
my voice many pauses along the way just
not talking at all but yeah no no no
it's very little to no attention on time
just trying to get the puzzles and I
guess with more practice the speed at
which puzzles are solved will improve
but yeah I'm not I started at the
beginning thinking I would do 3 didn't
know I would encounter this one yeah
tough if you're still with me Wow do you
have a lot of patience hats off to you
you get a give yourself a nice pat on
the back but anyhow feel free to share
how you did with this one did you figure
this for now you know did you leave the
video anyhow yeah feel free to share how
you did with these two puzzles in the
comment section below and maybe you got
something out of this lengthy one anyhow
that's all for now I hope you're having
a good day and I'll do another video
hopefully very soon that's all for now
take care bye
you